>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Mary Jane Deeb: Good
afternoon and welcome all
to the Library of Congress.
I'm Mary Jane Deeb,
Chief of the African
and Middle East Division
here at the library --
we're just upstairs -- and I'm
delighted to see everyone here
on this very rainy day.
We are a division, one of
the many divisions here
at the library, which
is responsible
for 78 different countries
including all the countries
of Africa, the countries
of the Middle East,
central Asia, the Caucuses.
We're made up of three
divisions: the African,
the Near East, and
the Hebraic section.
And we collect materials
from the region,
in the languages of the region.
And we are a medium-sized
division of 20 people,
specialists, people
who know the region,
people who know the languages
and the culture of the people
of these 78 countries.
And we are a -- we follow in a
way the mission of the library
which is we collect materials,
we process them, we share them,
we preserve them, and then we
serve them to our researchers.
But then in addition to this
we do a number of other things.
We have displays
of our collections
so that people can see
actually the items themselves.
We invite the authors, the
writers of these books,
and today is a case in point
with Ambassador Swanee Hunt.
And the writers themselves
are very much part
of what we consider our library
family because they are the ones
who create these books.
They are the ones who have
experienced the various
upheavals in the regions that we
cover and certainly the Africa
and Middle East Division,
the countries
for which they are responsible
have gone through a great deal
of turmoil and we can
say that one of the ones
that suffered most perhaps
in recent memory is
certainly Rwanda.
And yet there is not enough that
has been written about Rwanda.
There's not enough knowledge
in not only in the world
about Rwanda but even among
the scholarly community,
even among those who
have studied it most.
So when we invite speakers, you
know, we invite them to leave
after their discussion more
enlightened, more enriched,
by their own experience,
by their own understanding
of the cultures and the people
they have encountered while
doing their work.
We also increase
our own collections
by acquiring their books and
their research and sharing it
with patrons when they come.
As I was mentioning, our
division has specialists
and each one of our
specialists focuses
on a number of countries.
And among those in the African
section is Eve Ferguson,
and Eve handles east
Africa in particular.
She handles outreach,
acquisition, reference services
for the public and
also, as all of us are,
we serve Congress,
our first patron.
She also works on her own time
in the weekends and at night
as a freelance art writer
and she has taught literature
and writing at University
of the District of Columbia.
It is Eve who has actually
organized this program
with Ambassador Hunt.
But we are doubly
privileged today
by having also the Ambassador
of Rwanda, an exceptional woman.
Ambassador Mukantabana is
also a friend of the speaker.
And so we are thrice
blessed, if I may say so,
by having together the
Ambassador of Rwanda speaking
with Ambassador Swanee
Hunt about a subject
that we are all learning
more about and need
to know more about today.
And to introduce Ambassador
Hunt is our own Eve Ferguson.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Eve Ferguson: Good afternoon.
I'm very glad to see people here
this very cold, rainy afternoon
for a very special program,
something I've wanted
to do for a long time.
I am Eve Ferguson, Reference
Librarian for East Africa.
This is the third program
I've done on Rwanda.
The previous two were
on subjects that most
of us are familiar
about with Rwanda
and that is the 1994
Rwandan genocide.
We did a film, "As We
Forgive," and we did a book,
"Killing Neighbors,"
by Lee Ann Fujii.
The film was by Laura
Waters Hinson.
And I am really pleased today,
and it's always been my goal
to do a program on something
really good about Rwanda.
So today we are going to hear
from Ambassador Swanee Hunt
in conversation with
Ambassador Mathilde Mukantabana
about what is good
going on in Rwanda.
We know that there
are a lot of things
that are going well in Rwanda.
Rwanda's economy is wonderful.
The arts and culture of Rwanda
have always been notable
and just for my own interest
I have to mention Hillywood,
the Rwandan film industry
which is now taking off
and making its mark on the
African continent and beyond.
So there are wonderful
things happening in Rwanda
and today we're going
to celebrate those good
things happening in Rwanda
and they are happening
at the hands of women.
And we know in so many instances
women are the peacemakers
in the world.
We are the ones who bring
forth the next generations
and we are the ones who ensure
that those generations have a
fruitful and productive life.
So with no further ado, let
me introduce our author today,
Ambassador Swanee Hunt,
the author of "Rwandan Women
Rising" among other books.
You will see some of her books
in the display in the back,
including her autobiography,
but let me give you a brief bio
of Ambassador Swanee Hunt.
Swanee Hunt founded and
chairs Inclusive Security,
a Washington-based
nonprofit whose bold goal is
to transform decision-making
about war and peace.
Through government
constitution research,
leadership development,
and advocacy,
Inclusive Security
increases the participation
of all stakeholders,
particularly women,
in preventing, resolving,
and rebuilding
after deadly conflicts.
Her work in this area began
when, as the US Ambassador
to Austria from 1993 to
1997, she hosted negotiations
and international
symposia focused
on stabilizing the
neighboring Balkan states.
Her fourth book, "Rwandan Women
Rising," which came out in May
of this year, explores how
including women leaders enabled
Rwanda to rebuild after
the 1994 genocide,
setting a powerful example for
women -- sorry [laughing] --
powerful example for
countries across the world.
Inclusive Security
is one program
of Swanee Hunt Alternatives, a
private foundation she created
in 1981 which also combats the
demand for illegal purchase sex,
supports leaders of US social
movements, and advocates
for political parity of
women in elected office.
At Harvard's Kennedy
School of Government,
Dr. Hunt is the Eleanor
Roosevelt Lecturer
in Public Policy, founder of the
Women in Public Policy Program,
core faculty at the Center
for Public Leadership,
and Senior Advisor at the
Carr Center for Human Rights.
She holds two masters degrees,
a doctorate in theology,
and seven honorary degrees.
A Dallas native, she is a
widely published commentator,
photographer, and composer.
She was married for 25
years to Charles Aunsbacher,
international conductor
in impresario.
Her world includes their three
children and a menagerie of cat,
parrot, horses, bison,
and grandchildren.
And I do want to add, though,
that she is also a renowned
celebrity in Denver, Colorado,
where she lived for some time
and where part of
my family lives.
So she is also considered
a Coloradan.
So I would like to welcome
Ambassador Swanee Hunt
to say a few words about
our interviewer today,
Ambassador Mathilde Mukantabana,
who changed her schedule
in order to be here with us
today for this special program.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Swanee Hunt: I am
pleased tonight to be here
and to see several very
good old friends among you.
And thank you, Eve.
This is great.
And thank you so much,
for inviting us to be here
in the beautiful, beautiful
Library of Congress.
How did we first meet?
I don't exactly remember.
It seems like we've always
been connected at the heart.
>> Mathilde Mukantabana:
Several years ago,
when you invited
women at Harvard.
>> Swanee Hunt: Oh yeah!
>> Mathilde Mukantabana: Yeah.
>> Swanee Hunt: Yeah.
And be sure you speak
into this, right?
>> Mathilde Mukantabana: Yeah.
This. Yeah.
>> Swanee Hunt: You
have to turn it on.
The -- do you see the switch?
Yes. I think that's it.
Yeah, OK. I met Ambassador
Mukantabana and immediately knew
that I had come to know one
of the treasures of Rwanda.
She will tell you more about
her experience but let me say
that she has a deep, deep
understanding of her country
and the forces inside
of her country
that have led to,
really, this book.
And even though we didn't know
each other at that time --
and when she was there
to represent her country
to our country, you know,
that's a very, very big deal.
And I was impressed
with the wisdom
of President Kagame back home
in choosing you because you have
such a deep understanding
of the United States,
being tenured faculty
in history in California
and so I think having the larger
context in mind as you're able
to describe your country to our
country has been outstanding.
And may I begin by reading a
short passage and then turn this
over to you for however you
want to conduct this interview?
>> Mathilde Mukantabana: Hello.
Thank you so much, Swanee.
Please do.
>> Swanee Hunt: Alright,
thank you.
This is in the preface.
And again, and I wanted
to leave you with this
because it gives you
a sense of the whole.
Hundreds of conversations
I've had
over the past 16 years
revealed an untold tale.
Laden with personal burdens
but driven by an ethic
of responsibility,
women stepped forward.
In villages, mothers made
sure bodies were buried.
One initiated a countrywide
adoption program
that found homes for nearly
100,000 children whose parents
were murdered.
The stories of Rwandan women are
awe-inspiring in their passion
and startling in
their pragmatism.
The people around me were
women, says Father Emmanuel,
a newly ordained priest who had
lost his family in the genocide.
His first posting after
seminary was to a rural parish.
Their church had been burned
then bulldozed with hundreds
of desperate people inside.
Women helped me restrict
the parish, physically
and in terms of the community.
The way I saw it, men
were more affected
by a violence even though I
think women suffered more.
Afterward, men couldn't
do much but women saw
that they had no alternative.
And then my words, as chaos
cracked open the culture,
women were no longer
confined to hold the positions
of influence solely
in their homes.
Given the urgent needs
pressing all around them,
they expanded their leadership
at a revolutionary pace.
Still, this wasn't a
feminist uprising by design.
I think that's a really
interesting point for those
of us who have been part of a
feminist uprising by design.
OK [laughing]?
We didn't immediately think
of creating an organization.
Chantelle was a founding member
of a widows' organization
I visited in 2001,
now one of the most
influential civil society groups
in the country.
She goes on.
Most women in our
group were housewives
who hadn't had much schooling.
We met because we
needed to, to listen
and understand each other.
We needed to think
things through together,
like how to provide
for our children.
And then my words.
With a strong pull from the
new president, Paul Kagame,
women pushed for female-friendly
policies and prominent positions
in the government, led
initiatives to cope
with the traumatic
aftermath of genocide,
and establish businesses in
the extremely fragile economy.
Many who had found their voices
at the national level returned
to their rural communities
to encourage more women
to vie for public office.
These were women who
actually at that point were
in the parliament and instead
of simply enjoying their power,
they actually went back to their
rural districts and worked very,
very hard to get
other women to run --
not just for parliament,
for any positions.
In 2003, the first
election since the genocide,
women won 48.8% of the seats in
the lower house and parliament,
far surpassing the newly
mandated 30% quota.
In 2008 they took even larger
strides, securing 56% of seats,
and became the first
parliament in history --
anywhere in the world --
with a female majority.
Their gains were [inaudible]
political across society
when women took up
influential roles.
Does anyone here know what the
percentage is now, after the --
>> Sixty-five.
>> Swanee Hunt: Sixty-five.
Wow. On a good day, 64-65.
Right. Yes.
Thank you for knowing thing.
Now, isn't that astounding?
It's something that we across
the way here from US Congress,
we have no sense of that.
No sense at all.
And so as we talk about they
did this and that in spite
of the genocide, etc., etc.,
there was this pull from the top
and this push up
from the bottom,
I don't think we can have a
clue of what that really means
if we don't turn to
Ambassador Mukantabana.
In 30 -- it would
be the equivalent
of 32 million Americans
being killed
by their neighbors this fall.
Thirty-two million Americans
this fall being killed
by their neighbors.
But we don't have any way
to conceptualize that.
And yet, and yet you all,
you not only lived through it
but you surged into the opening.
But surging into the
opening sounds too positive.
Could you go back and give
us a sense of where you were,
what you heard, what you saw,
anything you want
about the genocide?
And then, even though we've
read a lot about the genocide --
we've seen movies and we can go
on and talk about this but not
without you really rooting
us in the background.
>> Mathilde Mukantabana:
Thank you so much, Swanee.
You read a very powerful passage
and I think it gives
a good beginning.
And quite frankly,
I agree with you.
You can't truly appreciate
what women have done
if you don't go back and
look at, you know, genocide,
and what happened in Rwanda.
You just mention it but you
can imagine for a country
that is the size of
Maryland -- very small --
when a million people
die within three months,
not killed by any calamity from
outside, by their own neighbors.
Three million people were
implicated in the genocide.
And you find that you have death
but also people leaving
the country.
You know, going to
neighboring countries
like the Congo, Tanzania,
and Uganda.
So in the 1994-1995, it
was practically empty.
You know, few survivors,
people coming back,
and the site was one
of blood, you know,
completely destroyed housing,
the few infrastructures
in existence but also
the bodies in the street.
You know, I have to tell you
in this whole stuff I lost
70 people of my own family,
including my own parents
and younger siblings.
And until 2009 -- 2009, it
was almost like yesterday --
we were still going
back to bury the dead.
We are still finding, you
know, hidden somewhere
because of a system of
justice that was telling people
to tell us where
the bodies were.
So the country was
but all destroyed.
And when we talk
about the destruction,
it's not just about death.
It's about all the institutions,
all the, you know --
when you can't count on your
own church because the majority
of the people died in
churches as you know.
When, then, you can't
count on your own family.
All the institutions were
completely affected by genocide.
You couldn't trust the state.
You couldn't trust the church.
And as a matter of fact, as
we talk about the whole area
of reconstruction
and reconciliation,
just a few months
ago the president
of Rwanda met with the pope.
And now we are trying to
put behind our understanding
about the church and
the brotherhood of men
and so on and so forth.
So what I'm saying is that
our country lost the soul
of the people.
We didn't really have much
to draw from, any experience,
any roadmap to rebuild
the country.
And when we come
back to the women,
for historical reasons
also, most women --
now in Rwanda they didn't
kill also the survivors.
The gender ratio was
skewed because of genocide.
The many left -- the others
were killed and we were left
with a higher percentage
of women.
But even starting with that,
they were the ones who were left
to mend the fabric
of a broken society.
They were married
to the killers.
They were widows.
They were, if anybody
who was victimized
by genocide it was the women.
They were raped.
We had a number of -- you
know, as a matter of fact,
if you go back and I know
that Eve would be interested
in knowing that there
is a movie on Rwanda
but on international
side, you know,
called The Uncondemned
that has been shown.
The women came to
testify in Tanzania
and now we know the crime
of rape is included
within genocide.
So we find a nation
that was completely --
we say maybe there was a
light still left shining.
That's why we were still alive.
>> Swanee Hunt: Right.
>> Mathilde Mukantabana:
And I think you can't
really find it anywhere else
but among the women who are able
to take chaff and grain and bad
and ugly and whatever
to mold, you know,
to put together families,
create new families,
and also really started
the whole arduous journey
of rebuilding nation.
And as you said, I would be
remiss if I don't also add
that we had a very
strong vision.
We had leadership that was
intending to empower the women
as part of the whole
community in the empowerment
of all the people of
Rwanda to become agents
of their own destiny, to become
agents in the reconstruction.
And women were central
in that particular area.
So before I finish,
I want to say that,
as we rebuild the nation -- and
I think Eve mentioned the fact
that Rwanda now is
doing pretty well.
I'm not going to brag but
we are doing very well
for a country coming
out of genocide.
And we've done even better
than what we were thinking.
But retracing these steps of
women, writing about women
and their empowerment
is also part
of that reconstruction
we are talking about.
So I need really to
give kudos to Swanee
because she took all this
time to write about women,
to interview women, to see
how they have been there.
This narrative of ascent
you were able to retrace
in your book and
thank you for that.
>> Swanee Hunt: Thank you.
Well I didn't mean it to
be a longitudinal study
but it turned out to be one.
>> Mathilde Mukantabana: Yes.
>> Swanee Hunt: Because I went
in 2000 for the first time.
But I don't want to gloss over
something that you said, and you
and I haven't talked about this
but when you said they went
to Tanzania to testify in the
court and now rape is, you know,
a crime of war -- actually, the
women who went from the village
of Tava, these are women
who had been gang-raped,
who had been raped until
they were unconscious,
who had been raped in the town
square, you know, 14 years old
and then impregnated,
etc. I mean,
these are horrible,
horrible stories.
And then there's a woman social
worker who starts working
with them in a group
and helps them starting
to tell their stories
and support each other.
Then you've got the
world court happening --
not the world court,
but the tribunal.
You had tribunal
happening over in Arusha.
And so the question becomes,
will any of them go and testify?
Now these are women
who are illiterate.
They have never been
outside of their country.
And they, with all they've
been through, they go over.
They walk into a room that is
much, much more sterile than any
that they've ever seen.
There are all these people in
these robes and they have --
they're speaking a
different language.
I mean, everything
about it is set
up to be disempowering,
everything about it.
>> Mathilde Mukantabana: Right.
>> Swanee Hunt: And yet they
testify about what happened
to them -- which is a taboo.
I mean, it's like -- so when
we say, "oh, and then they went
to Tanzania and testified,"
I mean,
that's such an example for me.
And you take an example
like yours --
70 family members killed.
That was all over the country.
That isn't simply about
Mathilde Mukantabana.
>> Mathilde Mukantabana:
That's -- exactly.
>> Swanee Hunt: That was
all over the country --
the trauma and the,
what we would call PTSD.
I mean, the whole
country was suffering
from post-traumatic stress.
>> Mathilde Mukantabana:
That's right.
Yeah. Yeah, go ahead.
>> Swanee Hunt: Well, no,
that's enough for me to say.
>> Mathilde Mukantabana: No, no.
You said it very well.
The whole country was suffering.
There was no family in Rwanda or
no individual who was attached.
You know, you can even imagine,
for instance, generations.
When we talk about generations
and the incredible task
we still have to continue
because when you talk about
reconciliation, when you talk
about building a nation,
it's an ongoing situation
because you have children.
Even, OK, two cases of
children I can give you.
They are products of rape.
You know, here you have a woman
who was victimized by somebody
who killed their husband
and you produce a child.
So these kids are
coming of age right now.
You can imagine the sense
of alienation they feel,
especially that sometimes
initially they were a constant
reminder of the wounds.
You know, how and when we talk
about our own reconciliation
in the country it's
not something
that is thrown at people.
Sometimes it's an intimate
voice, it's looking
in the eyes of that child.
And to say, "I'm going to love
you because you are my child.
You are Rwandan.
You are a victim
of circumstances."
But you have to understand
the human equation.
This is going beyond
the human equation
because in the eyes you
might be looking at someone
who victimize you, who
killed your husband,
killed your children --
>> Swanee Hunt: That's right.
>> Mathilde Mukantabana:
And so on and so forth.
But also for the
children who were born
from parents who were killers.
This is the huge
generation we have.
And that's what we've
been trying to mend.
You know, you are
not responsible
for the sins of the father.
And women were a
big part of that
because you raised the children.
You raised a new generation
of Rwandans, you know,
so that level of reconciliation
comes from the lowest level
when you are able to really
come together as people
and to say we are going to
create a new phenomenon.
We are going to come -- those
scenes are going to be cleansed.
It's what you are going to do
for your country
and for yourself.
And so the women have
that double task.
Even when we talk about women in
politics, if we talk about women
in the parliament,
you really have
to take all these
things together.
It's not just about
one job or another.
It's mending the whole fabric.
It's when you go to those
villages and, you know,
our parliamentarians are not
the ones sitting in offices.
No. They travel.
Each one of them is assigned
a village or an area they have
to visit to see that things are
being done but also the level
of how the families
are coming along.
And when I say families
and extended family,
quite a few lost
their own children
and now they are
raising the orphans.
>> Swanee Hunt: Yeah, but --
>> Mathilde Mukantabana:
But you know, yeah.
>> Swanee Hunt: The
amazing thing
that I've seen is
there'll be a woman --
and I will use the words
Hutu and Tutsi for you know.
And 90% of the country
was Hutu and huge,
huge number of the
group traders,
a huge percentage, were Hutu.
And so I say that because
I'll be with a Hutu woman
and she's talking to me about
having gone into the jungle
and brought her husband
out because he had fled
and he was the head of
intelligence for the Hutu
who were in Congo and who were
doing raids at night, you know,
keeping the war going.
OK. So as I'm in her home,
and I'm meeting her children
and there are three children,
and then there's
some other children
and they're hiding behind doors.
And everyone's playing and
laughing, etc. And I say, "now,
who -- are these
all your children?"
She said yes.
And so, and I said, but this?
You know, and I'm trying
to put it together.
>> Mathilde Mukantabana: Mmhmm.
>> Swanee Hunt: So two of
them are biologically hers
with her husband.
And then there are three
others and they are all adopted
but these are Tutsi children
who had been orphaned.
So she, in the middle of this
Hutu story, takes it for granted
that she's raising
three Tutsi children.
And that is something --
>> Mathilde Mukantabana: Yeah.
>> Swanee Hunt: I
saw over and over
and over in both directions.
>> Mathilde Mukantabana:
Mmhmm, mmhmm.
>> Swanee Hunt: I saw Tutsi
women raising Hutu children,
etc. You know, we
don't have a --
we just can't get our
minds wrapped around that.
I mean, that would be like
immediately after the liberation
of Dachau if you were to
say, well you German family,
we're going to give
you three Jewish kids
to raise or vice versa.
>> Mathilde Mukantabana: Mmhmm.
>> Swanee Hunt: We would
never think of doing that.
And yet that was
actually a practice
that was very much promoted.
It was natural but
it was promoted.
And you take those kinds of
practices and multiply them
by the dozens and the
dozens and you come
to understand how
women were able
to knit the country together.
And it wasn't just women
but women played really the
leading role whether it was
creating a justice system
because without justice it's
very hard to have peace.
So they created this
local justice system.
But they also created a health
care system and a system
to stop marital rape or other
kinds of gender-based violence.
And then they created this
whole reconciliation process.
And in each village there were
ways of getting the villagers
to tell their stories
to each other.
And I mean, there's one example
where there were these camps
that were sort of
reintegration camps
for the mostly men
who were in Congo.
So how are they going to
come back home, right?
But you've got to get
them to come back home
so that they won't be
the enemies from outside.
So you get these men
to come into this camp
that the women have
put together.
But then the women are
thinking after a month or two,
"where are these
guys going to go?"
Like, the only place for them
to go is back home
to their villages.
It's not like people have,
you know, a second estate
or something to go to.
So they've got to go home.
So the women start going to
these camps to sit in circles
with these men who have got
to be reintroduced to say,
you know, what's it going to be
like for you when you go back
and you have killed the
children of the people
in the house next to yours?
Like, how are you going
to deal with that?
And that kind of very
practical action that comes
from this hugely
generous spirit --
I will complete that thought
before we ask for questions.
But I want to complete
that thought with --
I was told of a woman who
went into that camp to help
with this reintegration, you
know, helping people think
through what it was
going to be like.
OK. And she sees the young
man who slaughtered her son.
And they were kids together.
And she sees him
and he sees her.
And there's this
terrible moment.
And then she says, "I want
you to come home with me."
And she says to him, "You don't
have a family to go home to
and I don't have a son.
So I want you to be my son now."
And she says, "When
you get married,
I'm going to give you the cow."
And that, for those of you
who know of this culture,
that is about as
precious as a gift can be.
And then she says, "And when
I die, this home is yours."
That's the story of
Rwanda over and over
as women led this
reconciliation.
>> Mathilde Mukantabana: Yeah.
And, you know, you
said it beautifully.
I just want to add that
all this was made possible
because of political will.
Because no matter how much
women can try to do it --
we've worked with many women
in many different countries.
Sometimes when it is that
level, political will,
and also the understanding
actually empowering those women
to do so, it can happen.
That's one of the foundations
to understand that even
like the settlement,
the reconciliation towards
the whole country program.
And the women came and
performed beautifully
within that general
country program.
So it was not an appendage.
What is maybe a takeaway
for me and, you know,
is that there was a
very good understanding
that once the vision on how to
rebuild the country happened,
the women became
actually the biggest part
of that reconstruction,
intricate part of
reconstruction.
But that thing was
embraced by all Rwandans.
Rwandans were given the
agency to do that and women,
in their area and even
beyond, they were able
to perform very more than
what we had dreamed of.
But again, it's that
kind of cohesion
between the women understanding
where the country wanted to go
and then the will
actually they led the way
in many different areas.
>> Swanee Hunt: There's
no question --
>> Mathilde Mukantabana: Yeah.
>> Swanee Hunt: That as I
said earlier it was pull
from the top.
>> Mathilde Mukantabana: Yeah.
>> Swanee Hunt: From
the top leadership.
That would include President
Kagame as the head of the party.
And then this push up.
>> Mathilde Mukantabana:
Yeah, push up.
>> Swanee Hunt: The women had
worked at a civil society level.
>> Mathilde Mukantabana:
That's so true.
>> Swanee Hunt: In these
women-only village councils.
It's a brilliant, brilliant
story of how they pushed up
and -- I want to
look at the picture.
This is the woman
who is the head
of the whole village
council system --
>> Mathilde Mukantabana: Sorry.
>> Swanee Hunt: Taking
the oath of office, right?
Should we see what
questions people have?
>> Mathilde Mukantabana:
Yeah, that would be good.
But I just -- maybe I start
with the question [laughing].
And many people might have the
same question but is to say --
this is a book, it's almost
like, you know, a labor of love.
You've written this
book for a long time
and you took your time.
You do your investigation.
You went to Rwanda.
You did many things.
Tell us why.
Why did you select
and want to do it?
There are many areas, you know,
of conflict and many places
where women also tried
to do similar things.
But, you know, and I've heard it
from you but I want you at least
to explain it to people.
Why Rwanda and why you really
invested all your emotional,
spiritual, physical, you
know, life to write this book?
>> Swanee Hunt: Right.
It was very personal for me.
It was, you know, in
our country, like --
as I said, you know, I've been
part of the women's movement.
And we thought we were
up against, you know,
all of this patriarchy
and it's terrible.
You know, we were making 49
cents on the dollar, etc.,
etc. When I was in my early 20s
I didn't have any understanding
of what women were
facing in other places.
And so as I began bit by
bit understanding more
about the world it became clear
to me that that's where I needed
to be putting my effort because
it would be so meaningful to me.
And having been brought
to Rwanda in 2000 to speak
at a meeting of several women,
maybe 20 women from the region,
and I was the only white
face there, and I came to see
that there wasn't any
place in the world
where women were facing as much
of a challenge as they were
at that moment in time in
that particular country.
And I wanted, because
I was hearing stories
and I actually also -- that's
when I met President Kagame too.
And I said to him, "you know,
if you want to change the face
of Rwanda, put women,
advance them
into the leadership positions."
And he did that immediately.
And they became, you
know, ambassadors
and they became members of
his cabinet in large numbers.
So I'm sitting here watching all
of this happen and going back
because I was so inspired.
And I had been involved
with the Bosnian genocide
and what they were doing in
Rwanda, what you all were doing,
was so far advanced of anything
that was being done in Bosnia.
And I eventually realized it.
I talked to one woman and she
would tell me about working
in the creating this
justice system.
And another woman would
tell me about being
on the constitutional commission
that got the 30% quota.
And another one would
tell me about, you know,
working in somehow, with let's
say the education system.
But none of them had
the whole picture
of how it all fit together.
And after I'd been going
for about five years I realized
that's the gift I could give
because I have the distance.
And I could analyze how
all of this came together.
>> Mathilde Mukantabana:
Thank you so much.
>> Swanee Hunt: Yes.
>> Mathilde Mukantabana: Yeah.
Maybe you can open?
Yeah.
>> Eve Ferguson:
We have enough time
to take several questions
from the audience.
I want to just put
out the housekeeping
that when you ask a
question you are agreeing
to be in our webcast.
This webcast will be available
later for people to view
on our webpage,
the African/Middle Eastern
Division Reading Room webpage,
as well as the Library
of Congress general
webcast at loc.gov.
So please speak your
question loudly.
We will then, I think that we
will ask the ambassadors to give
up one mic and then share
the mic as they answer.
So do we have some questions?
Yes. Young lady --
do we have, OK.
>> Thank you.
I would like to know
from Swanee [inaudible].
My name is Margaret.
I'm visiting from Nigeria.
I'm part of the women
[inaudible].
So it's really a
pleasure to be here.
You know, I want to
comment first with Swanee
and then the rest of it
for this group around.
You know, Swanee,
first thank you
for documenting what's
happened in Rwanda.
A month ago as the
representative of Rwanda,
you know that --
you know the story
of Rwanda is a great
success from every angle,
especially from the
women's movement.
My question is individual
[inaudible] structural governors
of conflict [inaudible].
So I just wanted to find out how
far you think we can all reach
success off the Rwandan.
Will it help in dealing with
the issues as I mentioned?
The [inaudible] you know,
the successes here
have been [inaudible].
Thank you.
>> Mathilde Mukantabana:
You can answer.
>> Swanee Hunt: I'm very,
very pleased to get asked this
because one of the lessons that
I draw out relates to this.
So I can give you a good
bit of stats which is
that illiteracy was at about 51%
for women before the genocide.
And now it's compulsory
education through ninth grade.
And that is extraordinary.
And that very much
affects, then,
the whole emerging business.
And because the women, when
they got into parliament,
one of the first bills that
they passed was the right
to inherit land and
then land reform.
And you know, that
right to inherit land --
you know, I never really had
a sense of what that meant,
how important that was.
That's like fundamental.
When you are living in a
home and your husband dies
and the whole home goes
to his brother or whatever
and then you become
impoverished and --
I mean, that's really basic.
And you don't have
that home as collateral
when you want to
start a business.
So it's very much all connected.
But the point I want to
hone in on when I look
at other countries: there's
so much ado about the idea
that unless you have
a certain higher level
of literacy you cannot have
women fully represented
as leaders.
That's just not true.
I mean, do the arithmetic.
It's not even math.
Do the arithmetic.
How many women do you need to
have as significant leaders?
100? 500? 4,000?
Whatever? Right?
Are you telling me that
there aren't 4,000 women
in any country on earth who
haven't had college degrees,
masters, doctorates, who
haven't been extraordinarily
well-experienced, who
haven't traveled the world?
Of course there are.
And so we have this false
relationship that we walk
around thinking, oh well
this is a really, you know,
this backward country
where women haven't had all
of these opportunities,
therefore they can't
be in leadership.
Those two don't go together.
Do you want to add to that, or?
>> Mathilde Mukantabana: One
tiny thing I can add that you -
whoops -- were to say it very
well but just what I'm going
to add, especially
for Rwandan women,
and you mentioned it
a lot and it's very,
very important for
Rwandan women.
But to think in terms
of after genocide,
people didn't have anything.
And among the things that were
done to empower the people,
to make people wake up --
that economic leverage, basic,
was part of the program.
It means that whatever
one has created
or what the women
themselves have done,
what we call homegrown
initiatives,
there were socioeconomic
programs specifically targeting
people with nothing.
Like for instance, what they
call getting a, have a cow.
Where do they distribute
the cows?
The sort of poorest
families can have
at least a basic,
basic beginning.
All the elements
of reconciliation
among women started
with economic initiatives, like
what they call peace baskets.
When they get together,
they do stuff together.
They bring a certain
economic livelihood
but at the same time they are
coming together as people.
So those are the things that
when you address your attention
to the health issues -- you
know, people were dying.
And the promotion of universal
health coverage was for that.
People were dying.
Even if you survived --
sometimes they were
dying from AIDS/HIV.
They were dying from
tuberculosis.
many diseases.
So tackling the issues of
health, tackling the issues
of poverty were also a big part
of our reconstruction efforts
that the women promoted.
Thank you.
>> Eve Ferguson: Do we
have another question?
[ Inaudible Comment
From Audience ]
>> Swanee Hunt: No, you're
Ambassador [inaudible].
[ Laughter ]
>> [Inaudible] Swanee.
This is the third book launch
that I've been at for this book
but it is the first time I've
actually read the book back
to back.
And I just wanted to say
[inaudible] and I'll try
to figure out how to put this
in the form of a question.
First, this is a [inaudible].
These are women who [inaudible]
or retracing history [inaudible]
through decades of
their country.
You put their comments
into context.
You explain beautifully
the messages
and really contain 16 years
of interviews [inaudible]
of pages of documentation.
And to put them into a book that
is readable and [inaudible].
The second thing I wanted to say
is the book is like [inaudible].
We all know what
man's done to you.
It's when [inaudible] or
it's already been 23 years
since the genocide, come on.
Or you know, where is the
focus on human rights?
Or why don't you tell
[inaudible] and Hutu?
And what you do in this book
is to say, we're looking
at this the wrong way.
We're looking at this
in [inaudible] the soul.
And this was not a question of
the human rights [inaudible].
So your ability to take it and
say to the men who are trying
to say to you, you don't
understand the context,
you're reversing that.
And in 300 pages
you say [inaudible].
I guess I'm going
to give up on trying
to ask this as a question.
[ Laughter ]
>> Swanee Hunt: You could
say, "what do you think
about what I just said?"
[Laughter] Ah, there is
a what I think of it.
OK? And that is that
after shock and awe --
you know, after we bombed
the hell out of Baghdad --
so I went to the Pentagon
and Don Steinberg knows this
because years earlier I had gone
to the State Department to meet
with him to say,
"hi, my name is" etc.
And so I do this
kind of advocacy.
So I went and I was
meeting with the general
who was running the invasion of
the US troops going into Iraq.
And so he was very
generous with his time.
He told me that I should
have another cup of coffee
and then have another
cup of coffee
and have another cup of coffee.
And I was going on
and telling him
about how this is the moment.
This is the moment you need
to bring women in to the core
of what you're doing through
our forces because if you want
to stabilize, those women know
which disaffected teenagers --
these boys have a weapon
under their mattress.
These women are the ones who are
perceived as less threatening.
So they can get into places
where the men can't get.
These are the ones who
have a whole history
of working across lines.
And I went on and on.
And he listened very
attentively.
And I said, you know, they have
tremendous leadership skills
that you can tap.
These are untapped resources.
And he listened some more
and he nods his head.
And then he said,
"Madam Ambassador,
I cannot thank you
enough for coming
and I appreciate your time.
And I want to assure
you that as soon
as we can get the place
secure we can think
about women's issues."
And I thought, I am not
talking about cervical cancer.
I am talking about security.
Well, to think how hard it is to
-- I mean, he gave me the time.
I said all the right
things but it's that context
that he didn't have, Don,
that you're talking about.
And he was a good guy.
He wanted to understand
but he just --
he was looking at it
from a different lens.
And that's what we mean
by inclusive security.
We actually have
to look at security
through a different lens that
includes the women of Rwanda.
You know, not as these
women who need our help.
That's the problem.
We see them as victims.
And you see this all the time.
Where do you hear about the
women leaders in any depth?
You hear about them as
victims, you know, and how,
oh well they became leaders
because so many men
had been killed.
That's not why they
became leaders.
I mean, that was one of the
circumstances among many
in which sparked all
kinds of their leadership.
But they were surging
into a chasm
when the chaos cracked
open the culture.
>> Mathilde Mukantabana: Right.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us loc.gov.